how much longer after Karl Marx wrote
his book Communist Manifesto we had a
country that was a communist country
running on his philosophies about 50
years right yeah
okay about 50 years of that so Nolan
came out in 71 it is now
2022.50 yours
there's not one country for libertarian
a time is now and the only ones you can
say maybe New Zealand's Got an element
of it but not necessarily fully there so
why why hasn't a if this philosophy is
so effective and so peaceful and so
necessary and so free why hasn't one of
these countries chosen to take it up as
their that as their you know way of
running their country well here's what
as Milton Friedman right as someone
you're a fan of I mean he would say it
this way right that if you want to look
the United States of America between the
end of let's say take the end of the
Civil War to about 1910. so about 1865
to 1910 in this and I'm not not saying
everything was perfect back then I'm not
saying it was a Libertarian Society but
economically speaking looking at it
there was no Central Bank there was no
income tax there was essentially no
Federal Regulation of the economy the
national spending was something like two
percent of the national income by
today's standards you'd be like this is
basically Anarchist there's literally no
government intervention and in this time
period we had the largest at the time
expansion of wealth the biggest
Improvement in the lot and life of the
average man in the history of the world
there's the wealth that had never been
thought of before was created now the
problem that I think Freedom has is that
also a Milton Friedman quote he goes you
know freedom is in the general interest
but it's not in anybody's special
interest there's the issue and so what
happens is as the wealth gets created
more and more the government tends to
siphon off at the parasitical class
tends to siphon more and more and more
and this grows the government and so
this is the issue that we've been
dealing with It's like because we're the
richest country in the world it was
because we were the most free country in
the world we become the rich country in
the world because we're the richest
country in the world we now have the
largest tax base this leads to the
government getting bigger and bigger and
now we have the largest government in
the world the largest most powerful
government in the history of humanities
the United States federal government so
that is the challenge but it's not as if
no countries maybe no country has
embraced the entire libertarian program
that's also true for Marxism it's not as
if any country really Embrace every
single word he ever wrote
um but the countries who have embraced
more freedom have been the most the most
successful countries in the world
um so we just I I think my view for what
the solution is to that is to create as
much of a Libertarian populist Uprising
as we can have yeah I think the more
people that believe in these values the
more Libertarians there are the more
likely
libertarian and independent
uh well I think libertarian is a
philosophical Outlook whereas
independent just means you are not part
of one of these two you know what I mean
or any major parties or any of the
parties one's a political affiliation so
you can be equal philosophy I mean you
could be both a Libertarian and an
independent or you could be a member of
the libertarian party and an independent
thinker but an independent could just be
something different than what the
establishment is whereas we are
something specific people who believe in
human Liberty and the reason that a lot
of Independents aren't coming to the
libertarian party and for that matter a
lot of most self-described Libertarians
aren't members of the libertarian party
so for example uh one of the best ways
you can judge if someone's a Libertarian
or not is how they register in their in
their voting in Most states the
difference between uh registered
Libertarians and states that have party
registering or have third party
registering and members of that state
party is 99 yes it's like one percent of
not and I'm not talking about the
population of the state I'm seeing
people that have already identified as
Libertarians are not joining the party
and the reason reason is and I think
this is what you're saying you're you're
not asking from a from a philosophical
standpoint you're saying why are people
not becoming Libertarians and I think
the answer is because our Focus has been
wrong we talk all the time about what
Libertarians are going to do for the
wars what we're going to do for health
care what we're going to do in DC and
with the Federal Reserve and those are
good things to talk about but long
before the vast majority of people who
actually decide who is in office decide
to give us a shot they want to see how
we're going to deal with things in their
backyard I'm trying to think about it no
and I know you are and the reason that I
coming out of the campaign the reason I
that I started you are the powers
because we're doing exactly that
localized Grassroots single issue
activism show people what libertarianism
looks like as policy how it actually
looks like in practice instead of these
great theories I can come in here and
sell you the best idea possible but if
it never happens then it makes just as
much sense for me to say you know the
way we're going to deal with China is by
me throwing magic thunderbolts at them
and then that'll fix it with the
likelihood of us winning the presidency
right now I might as well give that
answer it makes more sense for our main
Focus to be on where we're actually
already winning sometimes despite
ourselves which is at the local level
which grows us as a party it shows
people that we aren't this you know
utopian pipe dream it's actual Common
Sense feasible things that can be done
and we can build up from there and we
build the infrastructure because not
only when The Rock converts to
libertarianism will he be able to win
because we have the structure in place
but he'll want to in the first place
instead of just joining one of the other
parties and trying to change it from the
inside which never happens that's a
that's a scam there but the the reason
that they would do that is because right
now we don't have much to offer them so
we have to build from the ground up and
if we don't do that then we're going to
be here 50 years later talking about in
theory how ending the Federal Reserve
would end our 400 inflation rate in 2018
after I won ballot access and party
status for my for my party libertarian
part in New York I cross the state again
in 2019 after I had lost but I by the
way to your point there were 7 000
registered Libertarians in New York
state in 2018 I got a hundred thousand
votes he's a prototype of what I'm
talking about exactly that's why I'm
exactly what he said so then after that
I crossed the state again and in 2019 we
had 107 victories at the local level we
went from zero Libertarians to 107 in
one year and then the state afterwards
decided oh yeah we're going to change
the rules on how you can get in the
ballot so now we couldn't get in the
ballot anymore and you might say what
does that mean most people don't realize
getting on the ballot Just being on a
ballot so you can have a choice to vote
for me it costs hundreds of thousands of
dollars takes massive amount of people
are going to bet you came in the ballot
when the people Independence came to me
with tons of money and said Larry we
want to run into independent in 2022
people ask me that was 20 22 2020 I'm
sorry 2020 what about independent I said
great you're gonna have to have 40
million dollars and you probably won't
be able to get an offer these States
they're like what so yeah well we had
that money I know you can raise 50
million dollars but you can't get
through the red tape to be on every
single ballot in 50 states just run
libertarian we've already done that
already they're like we're gonna run
independent you can't if you could run
independent there'd be a president
Bloomberg right now you it's impossible
possible ballot access is one of our
biggest issues which is why I run to
gain ballot access so people can't on
the ballot and we just got hammered
again in New York state now I gotta get
45 000 signatures in six weeks and they
just made new laws that destroyed our
our local
um congressional districts so now
Congress people can't even get on the
ballot independent because there's no
Congressional let me let me ask you they
Hammer us this way tell me who is a
major influencer in America today that
has libertarian Tendencies would you put
musk in that category or no no I put
musk in that category Rogan in that
category absolutely I put Drew Carey
who's talks to seniors every day and his
team you put feel in that category yeah
the seals and academics he kind of like
he's certainly very interested in
libertarian ideas I think he he kind of
is somewhere between a populist yeah
musk what would you say musk is Muscat
is actually a left libertarian I think
so is Rogan I think both of them are
left Libertarians okay so who has sat
down with these guys to try to get them
to start selling the concept of
libertarian not Rogan I'm talking much
yeah I mean Rogan's uh Joe's a good
friend of mine um but there's in terms
of I've I'm trying to work on him to get
yes to get Peter Thiel and those guys uh
on board but I think that I mean it was
a guy to do that we've uh donated to Ron
Paul's campaign um I believe so so I
think he's well aware of these ideas
also weirdly enough uh Jack Dorsey like
tweeted out uh Murray rothbard article
man economy and state which to me is
like the greatest libertarian piece of
writing and well he's a big crypto yes
he's kind of in that world but I don't
it out something I don't know what his
deal is though like because he's like
now he's you know he's like Elon Musk is
right no one should be kicked off from
Twitter and you're like you know you
were there for a while man yeah I could
have heard of this Larry brought up
Andrew Yang we had Andrew Yang what a
month ago yeah and literally back he's
endorsed me I'm literally backed by the
photo oh my question okay so yep
he's starting this new uh forward
forward okay that's essentially a
competitor yeah libertarian party no no
an ally an ally it is an ally 100
because they want to break the duopoly
just like we do we got 100 allies okay
but aren't you guys
yeah we have heating for votes yes we're
all competing for votes but we are
allies in crushing do wobbly that's why
he realized you can't it's hard to run
within the party right he realized it
Hamas realized that toasty gabbard left
Democratic party I mean maybe not
officially but in reality she has
they're all leaving because everybody's
a two-party system doesn't work that's
why we're allies we are all allies it's
like when the Japanese invaded uh China
right the there were the maois And Then
There Were The Chiang Kai-shek people
they got together to fight the Japanese
that's us we're together to fight the
Empire oh that doesn't end very well it
doesn't it doesn't but let's hope we
change that we we learn from our the
enemy of my enemy is my friend 100. so
what about the green party we work
together I know Howie Hawkins how old is
my friend we're both Marines and by the
way Howie Hawkins is so far is so far
left we get our guns back he's actually
approached away he's a real socialist he
literally was he literally was the
Socialist Party nominee in uh in 2020
and he is my friend and we are
absolutely allies is there enough room
for all these parties that are getting 1
percent uh if if you add them all up and
we get remember New York state is a
plurality State I don't need 51 of New
Yorkers I need 35 of those who vote
there are 18 million New Yorkers about
12 million eligible to vote 10 million
register to vote about 6 million
actually vote so if I get about 2
million two and a half million votes I
win so I need about one in eight I don't
even I don't need a majority one in
eight and I'm a guy for the people you
were talking off camera how are the
conditions in New York what's happened
in New York the last 10 years oh my God
horrible New York we've lost over 2
million people in the past 11 years to
include this guy right here which makes
me angry but yes we've lost lots of
people from New York they all take off
and they leave and they leave because
we're too oppressive right our
government is so oppressive that it
breaks up Families my mother had to
retire and eventually die in South
Carolina because she couldn't afford
living in New York state and she left
her grandchildren for that it's terrible
New York state is a basket case where we
now have a budget that went from 170
billion to 220 billion well we're losing
millions of people
that math doesn't work we just keep
raising our budget we just keep making
things harder we keep it making more
rules and regulations we keep crushing
our families and then we wonder why
there's some Realtors are telling me
that a thousand people a day are leaving
if you guys have noticed that you have
some much louder more obnoxious
neighbors lately yes
I showed you the cover of the Wall
Street Journal about how Miami's are
basically up in arms about how much rent
has increased Florida is red because of
New York before it used to be a swing
state but we have exported all of our
Republican our red and conservative
voters to Florida we made Florida a red
state it was a purple State before
Jessica is there any state worse than
California I mean what's going on there
oh no I had a question for you about
what you think of the recent development
about in New York not even needing to be
a citizen to vote yeah they they can't
do it in federal elections but they can
do it in local elections that's going to
be coming to effect in New York and it's
a terrible idea for many reasons but one
of them is because it's only 30 days
which it just it makes it extra bad so
maybe I should go visit so I can come
vote for you you can great but yeah
exactly just stay for 31 days and you
can
you can in Newark city that's a city
thing not to say thanks a city thing so
if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]